pressure to conform to conventional
ideas about beauty is having dangerous
consequences in china
particularly among women it's leading to
increasing cases of eating disorders
like anorexia
and bulimia a study from 2019 estimated
more than 1.5 million chinese
were suffering from an eating disorder
i'll be talking to someone who's
experienced this
firsthand in a moment but first this
report
knows how to love and take care of her
own body today
but she learned it the hard way the 23
year old still has
vivid memories of the severe eating
disorder that
almost killed her at that time i was
around 28 kilograms
it was shot not long before i was
hospitalized
this was when i was being hospitalized
john says her self-esteem was low
affected by
extreme beauty standards shared on the
internet
like this one women comparing their
waists to the width of an
a4 sized paper such challenges are
common on chinese social media
they once convinced zhang that
skinniness will bring happiness
which only turned into a nightmare i
felt it could not walk by myself
my legs and feet didn't have any
strength my body couldn't function very
well
and i couldn't even see very clearly my
hair was very fluffy
and i hardly had any hair left i knew
that i was seriously unwell
but i didn't dare go to the doctor
now recovered chang helped organize this
exhibition against body shaming a
phenomenon experts say has skyrocketed
in recent years
this doll plastered with abusive
messages represents the pain and
struggle
many participants used to have
and this self-marriage ceremony a pledge
to cherish themselves for the rest of
their lives
it moved every single one in the room
i had always thought i was an ugly girl
since i was a kid
and thought that people only like
fair-skinned thin girls
and the process of my recovery i feel
that a healthy skin tone
a sturdy body and a strong heart are the
most important things
in this world
this is what zhang keeps reminding
herself every day
that confidence is what makes one
beautiful
john mina from hong kong is stephanie
ung
founder and executive director of body
banter a hong kong-based
non-profit that shares resources and
information on body image and
mental health stephanie welcome this
pursuit of the ideal body shape
are there any specific cultural factors
in china
for instance that are driving it
thank you for having me today um and i
can speak a little bit about
how there might be some cultural
pressures um based on my own experience
and
also in my research that i've learned
about and i think that something that's
really prominent
is that um there is there is a link
between
um the body the way that it looks and
morality
so um the way that we fundamentally are
so as a lot of us are familiar with um
there tends to be a belief that
um individuals who are in smaller bodies
are more disciplined
or more successful and individuals in
larger bodies are seen as
less disciplined or more lazy and this
link seems to be more pronounced in
chinese cultural settings
um that this link between physical
appearance and morality
in the sense that this association is
really fed to us from
a really early age and is constantly
reiterated in our daily lives
and something important to note about
this link is also that
it's really reiterated and reinforced in
mealtime settings particularly
because mealtime stuttering settings are
such crucial sites of interpersonal
connection
in chinese contexts so for example a
common idiom that's used in chinese
culture is that
if you don't finish your bowl of rice
you're going to marry someone who
has pimples all over their face um and
so it is through this kind of cultural
belief that links
um life outcomes with eating behaviors
that create such a complex linkage
between
how we eat how we look um and who we
fundamentally
are and and do these do these linkages
extend to other areas of daily life as
well for example in school
or in your peer group for instance
yeah so um it seems that um for
especially in
familial settings it is pronounced
because um these are the places where
you have this
intergenerational um passing on of um
knowledge
um but it definitely can extend to
school settings as well because these
are
um this is common knowledge common
cultural knowledge that can be
pervasive in all social settings so if
every
child has been fed this kind of belief
then um everyone in the peer group will
reinforce it as well
so yes i would say um that it is
pervasive throughout different
social groups stephanie how much of a
link
is there with social media for instance
and
the ideal version of beauty that we see
in our times
or is it just a case of the traditional
linkages that you were referring to
right now
yeah this is a question that i've
thought a lot about too um which is that
how much of it is
social media and how much of it is um to
do with cultural beliefs or
beliefs that we've been taught by our
family and i think that there is no
um there's no one answer to this because
um with eating disorders and with all
mental illness on
all mental illnesses it's a confluence
of factors it comes from
it depends on the person's individual
temperament as well
so if this person is very um is engaged
engages with social media a lot and
takes these messages to heart
then social media messaging may be more
um prominent
as a risk factor for them but if this
person is more um
feels more accountable to let's say
their family family's expectations
um or um or other kinds of expectations
that they receive
um then they would be influenced by
those factors more and you know in some
cases and in many cases actually
both of these things will come together
um and reinforce each other
um to create a very complex intricate
kind of pressure
so yeah and stephanie are these
struggles unique to just
women or do men go through these as well
um eating disorders don't discriminate
um they affect anyone
of any um any demographic trait so any
gender
um any socio-demographic um
socioeconomic status
um any um and and um and any background
and any cultural background so um
there's definitely no
um specific um group that is
exclusively um impacted by eating
disorders but um there's
obviously a different set of
manifestations that affect each group so
for example with women um there may be a
greater obsession with
thin ideal with men it may be manifested
in the form
of um of experiencing uh obsession with
the muscular ideal for example
so it manifests differently but everyone
can experience an eating disorder
you spoke about your own experiences
with eating disorders and i wonder if
that can help inform other people about
the warning
signs to watch out for what is it that
people
can watch out for to alert themselves to
what's happening with themselves
or with others
absolutely that's a great question with
warning signs i think
um that there are um a bunch of
different symptoms um
that can can manifest um but i think
something that's very important is
that linkage between morality and eating
behaviors so
a big warning sign is when the person
starts to say things like
you know if i don't eat a certain way
then i'm a bad person or the person
expresses this kind of belief because
when that happens um they can start to
engage in disordered eating behaviors
like
skipping meals like um you know binging
and purging these kinds of behaviors
become
integrated into the person's sense of
identity and then starts becoming a
pervasive pattern of behavior
that becomes a deep part of how they
behave and how they come to see
themselves
um so that is that's kind of a warning
sign when you start to see this sense of
attachment
sense of personal attachment to these
behaviors
stephanie we'll have to leave it there
for the time being but thank you so much
for joining us today with your
very insightful views on this
thank you very much for having me